>> Interesting answer, David, note that there are several factors in
David's answers. In the two situations that he thought were most similar to
a woman climbing up a ladder, in the similarity in the relationship, climbing up
as well as similarity between objects, woman and ladder. In contrast, one that
he did not think was really similar to a woman climbing up a ladder, woman
painting a ladder. Although there is some similarity between the objects woman,
and ladder, the relationship is very different here it is climbing up a ladder,
here it is painting a ladder which are two very different activities.
Between one and two we notice, that both of them have the same relationship,
climbing up, but an object is different, In one case it is the step ladder and
in another case it is a set of stairs. So one can have similarities in
relationships, one can have similarities in objects, of course some of you
may have different rankings with the similarities of the one they would give.
Because, your background knowledge might be different or your priorities might
be different, but the point here is the similarity can be measured around
several dimensions. Around the dimension of relationships, around
the dimension of objects, around the dimensions of features of objects, and
around the dimensions of values of features of objects that are participating in
relationships, we'll talk more about this in just a few minutes.